Hoàng Trung Quốc sẽ uống ngày 28 hình chiến đã ra lạnh bắt giữ bà hàng hát gia
lạnh đạo giáo hội thống nhất, liên quan đến gà buộc hồi lộ
có liên quan đến cự đánh nhất phục danh hành quốc, Kim Khoi,
Khoi Thế, toàn bán hàng lạnh bắt giữ với lý gió lòng này
bà hàng có thể tiêu hủy chúng cửa
nhóm công tổ viên đặc biệt tổn trước đã đến đi bắt giữ bà hàng với các gà buộc vi phạm lật quyết chính trị
lật trong tham dũng, số giúp tiêu hủy chúng cửa tham ô
bà hàng bị gà buộc thông đồng với một cửa quan trước của giáo hội mang họ yun
để đưa một chăm trị 1 tất khoảng 12.000 đuẩm lắm Mỹ
cho một nghĩ xí thuộc đảng quyền lực cuozan PPP vào năm 2020
nhằm đổi lấy sự giúp lợi cho giáo hội trong trường hợp ở dùng sức dân đặc cự tổn thống
ông dùng sau đó đã dành trên tháng trong cộng bộ cửa
ngoài ra bà hàng có bị niên liên quan đến việc tạo một giả dưới chuyển gà cấp
và tuổi chả nèo cho vào ở dùng là bà Kim Khoi
sử dụng tiền của giáo hội đến một qua và chỉ đã uống dù
têu vị chúng cửa trước khi cạnh sát dự chá ba
về cá vục lần bà hội.
Tuy nhiên giáo hội thống lất bà bò việc mà hàng có liên quan
cho rằng khai bị chên là gió cửa chức hỏi dự tự tự hẹn